[Applaudissements]
ouest
socrates ne dis pas que la seule chose
que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien
bon on y croit des galas mais bon
[Musique]
chez les élèves
bravo à ceux qui ont le bac je les mecs
bonsoir c'est bien c'est bon ça nous
fait six morts ça veut dire quoi à louis
hossegor où ça veut dire tu vas passer
un week-end de merde désolé pour ceux
qui sont au rattrapage
et hop à chacun son tour légal il va en
avoir besoin votre pote on va faire
comment nous pour la bagnole vous êtes à
bukavu qui que je vais admirer goût du
taf
c'est pourquoi cette année on y va
premier arrivé premier servi
chiche
j'y vais vous les a dans lé reste pas
longtemps
yum il va se retirer doigts du cul il va
bosser tout le week end d'accord ok tu
sens l'enfant qui devient un témoin
[Applaudissements]
on y croit lesquels à niveau
on a fonds en euros
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends tu es sûr que tu cplt ça toi
socrates ne nie pas que la seule chose
que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien
mais dans votre cas j'avais cru
comprendre